e
[Musique]
là vous at il des arbres et coupé non
juste à la fin de l'un trop tard et
quand je vous fais si l'amour avec moi
pas après vous envoyer
[Musique]
l'amour at il des ailes mon ami je le
crois coupable
vous avez mon ami côté de temps mon ami
2,3 je le crois d'accord mon ami envoyée
[Musique]
l'amour at-il désert on élit je crois
que si belle et je sais ce que c'est que
ça melian lors d'une animation sera
l'équipe et le dise que c'est elle qui
fait débat c'est pas en place c'est pas
juste non c'est pas aussi écouter ses
amis c'est très difficile moi je crois
qu'il vaudrait mieux reprendre demain
nous donnait raison elle est un peu
nerveux et sa maman une bonne nuit puis
demain il sera en forme ne frappe pas ma
petite chatte on va revenir demain ou si
tu veux je louerai la salle tous les
premiers se disent que tu l'auras et et
ce sera un succès autant dit ça pour me
faire plaisir mais non tu sais ce qui me
ferait plaisir maintenant on irait sur
seulement tout fourrure tout de suite on
irait manger du caviar et puis on irait
se coucher bon c'est tout pour ce soir
non un coaching mais celle là
[Musique]
dans l'île dans l'île dans l'île où le
diront il n'y aura que le soleil dans
l'île dans l'île dans l'île où nous
irons monsieur fontaine g de nouvelles
chansons pour quand vous faites montrent
envoyé avec laszlo il ne veut pas nous
recevoir
j'y peux rien c'est lui moi de l'école à
15 ans j'ai enregistré quatre faces ou
les médailles à deux ans ferme ses
portes ce soir
[Musique]
le ciel et jaune
alexandre cherche moi mes cigarettes tu
veux
papa tu es cigarettes
merci
v un concert le 7 juillet tu viens avec
moi charles perron il jouera le concerto
pour la main gauche de ravel
il est vraiment mon chou et de la main
droite
ça tombe bien car elle n'a rien écrit
pour la main droite c'était un bon
copain en avril 45 en hollande
deux jours avant la fin de la guerre il
a gardé une grenade trop longtemps dans
la main là ma droite tu t'en fous tu
sais moi les anciens combattants c'est
pas grave en 40
je sais mais charles était destiné à
devenir un grand pianiste tient en
angleterre une fois eh bien on était
tout près d'une gendarmerie occupée par
les allemands il fallait lancer la
grenade de façon qu'elle expose à
l'intérieur alors charles a visé la
fenêtre en comptant jusqu'à 5 seulement
elle a explosé avant quoi bah tu vois il
me reste un beau ici après la guerre
charles appris à jouer de la trompette
mais il regrette toujours le pied nous
comment ça trompe at il n est
artificielle
les seules fois où il passe une fleur à
peu près humaine dans tes yeux c'est
quand tu parles de tes amis à ces
moments là on pourrait presque croire
que tu n'es pas à nours vraiment fait
pour vivre comme un primitif dans la
chasse et la bataille en compagnie des
hommes des femmes aussi bien sûr mais
sans amitié pour elle jamais une
partagera de thé secret avec une femme
il n'y a plus de complicité entre ton
fils de toi qu entre toi et moi tu parle
comme un livre
tu aurais dû rester maîtresse d'école oh
pardon professeur il n'a tenu qu'à toi
de ne pas me bousculer au restaurant
d'une part envers cette attaque de café
sur moi il ya dix ans je suis prêt
près à quoi et à la fête y est tu nous
la promet du tout vient
[Musique]
ans
bravo monsieur vous avez gagné la ville
la mairie à dos
c'est le gros lot j'avais gagné la coupe
et voulant porter
[Musique]
il est longtemps côté ma fatigue
ado je dis qu'il ya longtemps que tu ne
m'as pas dit ni la mort c'est pourquoi
tu tombes il devient ferrato avec moi
pourriez demander pardon non pardon
acquis pauvre cave à moi d'abord mais à
mon fils ensuite et bien poliment
[Musique]
je ne demande pas pardon
jamais non
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe une bagarre ces
frais de haut qui règne dans ce type est
mise à leur manager entière il a sonné
un mec certainement tu sais rien fred ne
connais pas il n'a jamais travaillé chez
nous on nous ferme en pleine saison il
ya plus qu'à mettre la clé sous le
paillasson
oui
[Musique]
la prochaine wii
je ne peux pas le garder contre son gré
mais s'il prend des risques
remarquez il a une solide constitution
oui il peut à peine parler
il a réussi à nous insulter enfin je
viens fait signer une décharge comme il
se doit vous avez une voiture
oui
[Musique]
m
bien
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est moi après des hauts
salaires en tirant j'ai oublié mon sac
et mon blouson j'ai tout mon fric de
temps j'étale données tarde pas les
flics sont venus le type yachts a sonné
c'était un gros ciom la patronne indiqué
tu connaissais pas tu étais pas de la
maison
et toi si on interroge moi pareil tu as
intérêt toute façon personne connue mono
non
ma voiture plus tard pour maintenant on
rentre
je ne savais pas que j'avais un mari
bagarreur trop vieux comment j'ai trop
vieux
[Musique]
vous avez une constitution de jeunes à
mon dieu mais vous ne pourrez pas bouger
avant 15 jours ni ouvrir la bouche avant
un mois pour les côtes ça s'arrangera
tout seul mais pour les danses d'autres
choses à mon avis vous en avez au moins
5 de perdus vous avez un dentiste
demandez lui de venir vous voir
j'ai en même temps que lui nous
enlèverons le plâtre il pourra peut-être
faire des empreintes et vous préparez un
appareil provisoire en attendant que
vous puissiez vous rendre chez lui je
vous ai prescrit des calmants
moi j'en prendrai ce soit merci vous
avez eu une idée de la raison pour
laquelle ce personnage vous a mis dans
cet état
c'était tellement tout de même qui se
soit acharné sur vous à ce point là je
vous a peut-être pris pour quelqu'un
d'autre
claude fontaine 50 ans a été sauvagement
frappé par un inconnu dans une fête
foraine
c'est graoui
on ne peut pas parler il sous l'effet
des calmants oui dit qu'il sera réveillé
je le lui demanderait il compte sur vous
pour que rien ne se sache à l'extérieur
ce n'est pas monsieur fontaine lazlo
c'est moi à monique monsieur fontaine a
eu un accident de voiture il est couché
je crois que c'est grave avec votre
accent c'est presque charmants et dit
rien aux autres
cigarettes non tu n'as pas le droit de
fumer si tu touches tu vas avoir
affreusement mal aux côtes
c'est un visage intéressant comme ça je
ne savais pas que tu avais la barbe
blanche
mais là qualys madame j'ai entendu tu
veux les recevoir
il y avait une convocation pour toi ce
matin mais j'ai dit que je ne pouvais
pas me présenter c'est pas un accident
qui l'a eu j'ai vu la voiture elle avait
pas à lyon quand madame la ramener
bonjour messieurs mayhem suis monsieur
claude fontaine je ne veux fatiguerait
pas vous avez été victime avant-hier
soir d'une agression nous avons essayé
d'interroger quelques témoins mais une
royale ou ici pecho pardon mais c'est
mon fils était présent il m'a tout
raconté les enfants à cet âge et davies
a observé que nous cet homme avait les
cheveux noirs une moustache et sur le
bras un tatouage un coeur avec des
chaînes est un mot qui commençait par m
à d'ailleurs il m'a fait les seins je
vais le chercher
nous avons déjà enregistré la décoration
des enfants le soir même
[Musique]
je
d'après le vertige
je vais rester à la hausse combien on
paye 520 plus la prime de risque
d'accord bon ton nom la diva vié
bon ça va tu commences amélie et où
dormir sinon une baraque avec douche de
sur la mer et portugais on est loin de
tout ici je veux aller chercher tes
fringues et pour quinze jours de travail
s'est du coup j si tu as tu éviteras des
prêts de france pour voilà c'est tout
est-ce que vous portez planète monsieur
non comme vous vous dans les messieurs
mais je vous signale que si vous n'en
avez pas d'action civile l'action
judiciaire se poursuit hier il ya eu
scandales sur des prêts publics
[Musique]
il faut extraire le bloc incisif et la
gamine supérieur gauche donc qu'un jour
je vous pose l'appareil provisoire ne
cédera pas ouvrez mort des ouvres est
hors d ouvrir parfait vous allez vous y
faire au début vous aurez l'échevin
tente un peu difficile alors entraînez
vous à dire aristophane à chercher
xénophon et surtout surtout ne mangeait
pas d'artichaut alors je vous poserai
définitif du cians mois et plus tard
quand tout cela ne sera plus comme
mauvais souvenir
ne vous mettez pas devant une glace pour
retirer votre prothèse
car ça fait quand même un gros trou on
ne peut rien envisager de fixe alors
donnons le bridge serait trop long oui
non souriez par fait partie ariste fans
chercher ses deux enfants on dirait un
message personnel comme à la radio de
londres pendant la guerre
[Musique]
des cigarettes
non merci j'ai peur de tout si vous avez
déjà à me faire entendre vos pas mal bon
allez il rejoint
ne me regardez pas comme ça tous les
deux bah oui je me suis fait casser la
gueule et alors ça peut arriver à tout
le monde non
[Musique]
pourquoi tu lui fais part faire un
disque invendables y en a 50 avant lui
sur la place de paris d'un copain est
alors pas une raison pour faire un
mauvais disque qu'est ce que tu deviens
j'ai ouvert une pâtisserie ma femme
affaire d'héritage
je suis placée entre deux églises
je fais 17 messe le dimanche j'ai du
voyage qui bouffe et toi tu as retrouvé
le mec qui te met un sacré alors la fête
des ménages est bien entendu personne ne
le connaissait
enfin la police fait une enquête
c'était moi
mais serait pourléché [ __ ] des tartes
dans la gueule tu parles comme à
pâtisser tu sais ça pour toi elle nous
tous on aurait pu donner un coup de main
j'ai une idée dès que c'est fini je vais
enfin le choix quant à l'action du
canadien aux polonais dans le quartier
d'eric à une patte et dérivés effacés
c'est bâclé farah c'est fou ce qu'on
peut se défigurer en 30 ans et dire que
ces mecs là qui tirait la thomson
foutait la trouille moche le béret rouge
sur blanc dans le coup
toi tu as gardé la forme je vois la
salle
c'est ça tout les pertes humaines en
remercier henri le costaud
il a monté une petite affaire de
surveillants
en perfection tout va ils font mais les
gants j'ai beau dire qu'il a gardé le
chantage je me suis bien de lui mais ça
amène à tous les bars je vais donner son
adresse il va te retrouver ton mec qui
te dis que j'ai envie de le retrouver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai oublié les paroles
merci pour l'écran
voilà voilà
[Musique]
alexandre c'est toi qui est ouvert nous
enveloppe tu avais déjà déconnectés
jouer ça te suit banon pourquoi n'as-tu
sortie bien pourquoi claude sarraute
anglais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
qu'ils osent times descendra du ciel du
cracher le feu inter c'est naturellement
le centre du monde pour un garçon vitois
en plus tu es un père qui est un héros
le jour où le héros se fait casser la
figure par un inconnu le monde s'écroule
pour lui il t'a vu la terre te
protégeant contre les coups c'est lui
qui me l'a dit ne comprend pas il veut
que tu redevienne son héros si la sortie
tout ça c'est pour te rappeler ce que tu
étais pour lui merci pour toi aussi je
suis un vieux goudron claude je t'aime
je suis fier de toi exemple
on
tout proche
écoute mon garçon je ne suis pas plus
fort que les autres
ayant moi le fait j'étais surpris tu
crois que j'ai oublié tu trompes vais
retrouver celui qui m'a frappé père à sa
mort ça peut prendre un certain temps il
en attendant on est copains comme avant
quoi tient le raf on voit le juré
claude fontaine ancien combattant de la
france libre va demander un compagnon
d'armes de l'aider à retrouver l'homme
qui l'a sauvagement frappé un mois avant
dans une fête foraine
je regardais vous avez accroché mon
basse s'est plaint des charges ici voir
monsieur marc cela est il était à la
salle il se fait les muscles comme si
l'on n'avait pas assez
[Musique]
en double
c'est
[Musique]
au clown ory je te prenais pour un
client
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là mon pote
je viens de voir que tout se passait
[Musique]
bien dépendre de fairview
c'est bien tout journaliste je dérange
et qu'on va parler de toi le petit chien
à aa
menchov le démarcheur l'allemagne raddho
et qui finit le millefeuille fait nous
dira si 50 verges il est fait pour et
moi autres s'avèrent encore fauté
cheveux non c'est le voyage qui layton
qui me dira dans le disque c'est pour
laisser sert d'avoir des muscles non -
si je m'entraîne ce pour rester en forme
d'un coup ses civic reçu faut pour alors
je salue bien
que bob marley autre part d un cancer
ces personnels qui suit
[Musique]
mardi
à présent moyens venant de poils qu'on a
bien fait le peloton nom était fait pour
être un chef
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour toi
cher voilà j'ai été attaqué par un
inconnu un mois et je voudrais te
retrouver avec et comment or dans une
fête foraine pour une bêtise magazine 5
dans des côtes et en motivant du crâne
elle est après le disparu moi je croyais
que c'était un employé des scooters tu
sais les encaissèrent deux ans mieux
acrobates leçons d'une voiture à l'autre
il paraît que dans la police a fait une
enquête mais j'ai eu aucune nouvelle
alors j'ai pensé que tu pourrais
peut-être de poupées de ce genre de
travail du boulot j'en ai trop et ne
suis là me paraît un peu compliquée et 2
et travailler pour toi cette sous
tendant les endurants chef terminée et 3
souviens pas
c'est moi et qui portait son sac et ton
fusil pendant les marches forcées en
écosse avec mon couteau que je regarde
des ampoules pendant que tu râlais je
suis descendu au ballon avec toi quand
tu as couché à casquette du colonel 30
jours et le crâne rasé
vas-y aux risques courent c'est bon
c'est moi et ils balançaient la gamine
pendant que toi tu second quoi bayonetta
thompson mais quand je le veux une fille
que je demandais traduit c'est toi qui
la faisait pas ce que tu parlais anglais
bill dispatcheur taper comme ça parce
que tu cites est tout le temps
shakespeare jeunes gens de la famille
c'était boîte des chefs comme toi et les
pénuries com - pour des hommes de troupe
seulement quand les jeunes gens de bonne
famille ont pris du bide
il ya une chercheure effectué comme bas
pour faire un boulot c'est fini
bon maintenant écoute
si j'avais pas vu la tête des opérations
quand on était perdus dans la nature
connaît plus d'à peine qu il serait plus
là pour me le reprocher et dames situe à
porter mon sac c'est une voulez bien et
de deux et si je me suis fais tes filles
c'est parce qu'elle n'avait pas de
groupe pour le muscle et de trois
constats jour mon salon mais j'ai pu un
temps finit par atteindre situe pour
trouver le mec qui stationné froid de
prendre par la main pour une fois en
décroche tout seul ça s'appelle avoir
une femme dans la peau
elle est belle t'as pas une photo
ou tu vas après le chantier là
[Musique]
beaucoup
oh
[Musique]
vous pouvez partir alors
si le peuple aurait tout de même très
bien avec moi ça fait du bien d'abord tu
as ainsi c'est ce qui nous fera du bien
à dresser seul bonjour docteur non merci
merci à la vie
[Musique]
on va le retrouver
je vous en prie voilà à très bientôt je
vous le promets on va à la fiche ac
qu'est ce que vous foutez encore à
quatre pattes je sers sma durette et
puisque vous le prenez sur ce ton je
vous annonce que si vous ne me sentais
pas à ma machine jaune des initiants
votre buret sait moins qu'il ait caché
parce que j'en ai marre d'avoir du
courrier qui ressemble du papier
englober le beurre et puis si vous
démissionnez moi je vous vois la porte
cette machine marche très bien c'est
vous qui savez pas frappé claude
fontaine après avoir été rebutées une
première fois par an 8 marcellin son
ancien compagnon d'armes de la france
libre revient à lui demander son aide
pour retrouver l'homme qui l'a
sauvagement frappé j'ai gros frais
et oui alors tu reviens pourtant
l'histoire
oui j'y réfléchis tout ce que tu m'as
dit est vrai mais tu vas me retrouver le
type qui m'a sonné à la fête
non non attends j'ai presque 50 ans
j'ai une femme qui est plus jeune que
moi et j'ai un garçon qu'est dix ans il
était avec moi quand j'ai roulé dans la
poussière
il m'a vu me protéger les coups de pied
comme un gosse skipper des claques
je ne suis plus rien pour lui pour ma
femme je suis un vieux avec la moitié de
la mâchoire qui n'est présent me nourris
avec de la bouillie pendant quinze jours
depuis c'est arrivé plus rien n'est
comme avant pour reprendre une vie
normale
il faut que j'efface cette histoire de
ma tête et de la leyre et pour ça y'a
qu'un moyen rendre ce voyou les coûts
qui m'a donné es tu lui aura tout seul
ça dépend de toi moi oui tu le retrouves
et tu me remet en forme j'avais bonne
pêche dans le temps s'arrête pas je vais
pas de résistance
t'as jamais su encaisser alors comme 30
ans sont passés qu'est ce qui te reste
un tas même plus le prévenir tu vas
encore montré dans un coup d'oeil
et puis lé final qu'est-ce qui va payer
l'addition série à tanger pas fini se
souvient de la bagarre et fitch la nuit
on s'était réuni avec les polonais les
belges et les écossais pour [ __ ] sur
la gueule aux ricains soit tu t'es bien
battu je reconnais mais qu'est-ce qui
cet appel est une pure avec leurs
matraques 1 c'est bibi dans l'état où tu
as tiens ça donne pas une minute devant
un grand jeune et un peu teigneux on se
battait pas qu'avec les points on a
appris pas mal de choses pendant
l'entraînement on a appris à tuer mais
c'était la guerre je n'ai rien oublié
il n'a pas l'intention de le tuer
retrouve le mois saint lô
je leur trouve une fois que c'est fait
tu le flingue un sens de salir les mains
ont été fort revolver et c'est ça que tu
appelles rendre les coups dire que j'ai
failli marcher mais qu'est-ce qui me
trouve que ça s'est passé comme tu me la
raconter qu'est-ce qui me prouve que tu
ne recherche pas pour autre chose ce
sont des mecs 30 ans ont passé mehtarlam
même qu'elle ait les mêmes dieu quand tu
as envie de tuer tiens c'est ses yeux la
qui a vu le faible à groningen avant de
mourir quand tu as des charges et ont
connu que dans le fond c'était lui ou
moi ou toi je te le redis pour la
seconde fois de retrouver je me battrai
son tour lui avec mes mains avec mes
pieds même avec la tête ils vont
la burette à figeac
l'as monaco
il va en avoir besoin pourquoi
elle entend notamment mis les gants
teleman jeune fille si vous êtes battre
un jour toutes les 4 premiers coups bon
je vais trouver un petit grain peu moins
lourd que toile
et si tu tiens trois minutes devant lui
je m'occupe de toi tu aurais c'est
d'ailleurs sa garde si on bosse 3 comme
en angleterre
le gaucher le pas de côté ça prend plus
et puis ta droite lagarde au frigo pas
sorti la balance je serai déjà content
très alléchante un peu ailleurs
baisse - oui 15 tiens mais un protège
dents parce qu'il en reste et en aval
c
west a le monde à ses risques
tu vois le but jusque là bas c'est un
vieux copain mais on a fait un pari
toledo qui tueraient pour trois minutes
devant toi whissell et rennes 50 plus
mais tu va sonner au corps par la tête
en a besoin pour son boulot il y en a
pour son argent et moi aussi dire à 5,5
pour toi trois minutes
encore une seule cause
leur tendre les
ouais
ap
[Musique]
ça suffit les trois musées m'a fait mal
mais j'aurais jamais cru quoi je
tiendrai trois minutes mais toi tu me
toucherait ça fait mal
je crois qu'il ya trois mois ont battu
allait prendre sa douche et trois
billets se fera un pansement pour is
love bientôt il va coûter une connais tu
lui envoies souvent des clients quelques
fois c'est moi
[Musique]
tu le dis a plus jamais aux réunions des
anciens jeux rares des âmes qui
racontent leurs souvenirs aurait été
c'est tout quatre ans de leur vie c'est
en fait trente ans de parle 15 la fin de
la guerre ils n'auraient rien à dire moi
j'ai continué à me bagarrer
un jour il faudra qu'ils me racontent ce
que tu as fait depuis
ça fait au moins bâtons qu'on s'est pas
vu bassil s'est pas cassé la gueule tous
les jours en fait on a l'occasion de se
revoir
je vois tu fais de toi c'est drôle je me
sens presque mieux que nous respirons
vieux y accédera elle je pense à la tête
qui va faire ta femme brillante
vous pouvez parler vous savez j'ai pas
mal aux oreilles des tous mus et au
square et un enterrement
oh moi j'ai rien à dire monsieur c'est
encore heureux merci gabriel tu sais
avec la tête que tu fais personne n'a
envie d'avancer la parole j'ai la tête
que je veux faudra vous y faire ça
risque de m'arrivait souvent ça va durer
longtemps
jusqu'à ce que je le retrouve et le jour
où j'aurai retrouvé vous pourrez priez
pour moi ou pour lui
[Musique]
mon cher fontaine nous avons été surpris
par la fréquence des accidents de
voiture que vous avez en ce moment nous
avons pensé que vous étiez surmené qu'un
peu de repos médiatique ainsi j'ai pu la
confiance du conseil d'administration je
peux vous offrir ma démission
l'un d'entre vous sera sûrement prendre
les disques fonds énormes trouver de
nouveaux talents les commercialiser
disputé avec les apr ès arts ea loin
nous cette pensée est mon cher fontaine
mais vous comprendrez que les capitaux
que nous avons investi au fond vous
pourriez peut-être prendre un chauffeur
j'ai mieux que ça monsieur triquet
beaucoup mieux pour veiller sur ma santé
on se présente simon le photographe un
artiste langeac tout dans la tête et
dans les bras robert le taxi entre
autres marques
il écrit des policiers qui se vendent
dans les gares et pierre jo champion des
légers avant la guerre un ange il fait
dans les veines
lucien celui là rien lui coupent
l'appétit sauf la promesse une bonne
champagne
prenez les doigts en or mais pas
d'initiative oui monsieur fontaine qui
veut donner quelques détails
supplémentaires
j'ai apporté un petit dessin fait par
mon fils il est vu comme beaucoup mieux
que moi il avait hâte à tout âge sur
l'avant bras
[Musique]